well anyone who wants to change the
world the first question you have to ask
is who's your what your goal and who is
your target audience and so the very
first thing I want them to think about
is you know for the vast majority of
causes it's women who are the really the
ones driving the social change so and
now that we know through cognitive
science that men and women are different
we're really different and this has been
a big hurdle for people to overcome
because somehow admitting the women are
different than men somehow means to some
people that were not equal and I think
this wave of feminism the one I'm in
third wave can recognize that you can be
different and equal that's the next you
know big feminist frontier so first you
have to recognize that for the vast
majority of our work women are the
target audience that's not to mean that
you exclude men but and in marketing
there's this principle called the long
list principle and women are much
juicier shoppers we're the tougher
customer so we may have a list of 12
things we really care about you just
think about if you're walking through
the aisle of grocery store it's women
reading the back labels of the soup cans
we're really detail-oriented we're
really sort of tough for customers to
get men usually have very specific
things they're looking for so if you can
reach the woman's 12 things you can also
get the men's three things that they
care about so it's actually you know if
you hit the she spot people have asked
me what's the she spot and I say it's a
woman's heart and head where typically
women think of it when you think of
women you think of their their hearts
like we're soft and we're mushy and we
only care about that but it's also it's
our heart and head we really put those
things together but if you hit the xi
spot you can hit the heat spot too you
know and I think that's really important
there were four major principles and
connecting with women
one is care women are are deep with
empathy we we tend to really care about
the things that were involved in and to
care about the planet so when you
communicate with women it's important to
tell real-life stories you know when we
knew will you watch Home Depot ads it's
about you know Jane Smith from Houston
and how she's building a new kitchen or
a baby's room
so tell real life stories use humor
really really important when connecting
with with women use optimism you know
you want to communicate I think I can
versus the sky is falling you know think
the little engine that could versus
Chicken Little that's that's really
important but don't forget to leave out
the details women really want to know
the details of things some people will
go with a really good story but then
they won't back it up with the details
around the policy so women are actually
really looking for that the second C is
connect women really want to connect to
an issue they really want to connect to
each other and so when you connect women
to each other around a cause you
actually strengthen your brand
corporations completely understand that
think of Avon for example it was about
you know connecting women through
parties or Tupperware they would connect
women through parties so organizations
who connect women to each other totally
strengthened their plant brand and this
is what you know Hillary Clinton is
doing and Barack Obama is doing is
creating sort of these women groups
that's really really powerful
the next is cultivate when it comes to
raising money for an organization a lot
of people are like oh it's men who write
the big checks and while it's true that
a man will write a big check faster it
takes women a little bit longer to make
a commitment but once they're committed
they're gonna stick with it to the long
haul so make sure that you think of a
long term sort of fundraising or
advocacy strategy with women that's
super super important and women are
twice as likely to pass on information
as men so you want women in your ranks
because they're gonna be instant sort of
promoters of your cause and then the
last C is care connect Oh control the
last C is control and this is really
important you know women are we tend to
be busier than men because by the time
is interesting by the time were 40 years
old 80 percent of us will have children
which means that most of us are taking
care of kids and having a career some
people aren't some people are doing a
little bit differently and even some of
us are taking care of our parents and so
we're living pretty busy crazy lives the
last thing you want to do is show her
that that she's busy like she knows that
she's busy you don't have to remind her
how busy she is but what you want to do
is provide her opportunities to get
involved in there cause that creates a
two-for-one for example you want her to
get involved in protecting the
environment why not give her a car
bird that has all the different types of
fish you can buy that don't have mercury
in it so she can put in her wallet or
why not allow her to buy a gift for
someone on their birthday or for
Christmas that also is a donation to
your organization why not allow her to
go online and get a shopping bag a
renewable shopping bag and then at the
same time donate five dollars to you
know save the salmon you need to think
about ways to engage women that can get
them involved that fits into their time
schedule give women opportunities to do
things with their children online games
fairs you know they're coming to their
activism and their political work is
full human being so you want to bring
the family into that too